we work out six houses yeah somebody's
got to do it I also just hide my shoes
it's just unheard of
[Music]
baby
[Applause]
this was last Monday morning in your
life and not just a couple FL we never
turn it up giving you one of my heart
ever written it up an energizer look
about in the record repugnant pundits
that push agendas and pass judgment I
covered this time to 21 and I'm being
honest these moments never that I sit
and watch on passengers but still far
down for the crash - mr. Mandic is my
number tactic is now but I made the fact
that we used to get monotonous because
my dental practice senator Roberts
reports of X that I know with all its
Emery and exists every continent it's a
very similar they very mountainous horn
applies for the soul but it's all
supposedly a friend of mine I would
argue everybody in theory there's nobody
you can't have as a customer so the
reason for 700 bucks that I would go to
a meme account that has three million
followers on Instagram to do a post is
just the sheer volume of attention for
that $700 is going to create this should
we sure got it in my sermon that works a
whole lives I've seen them struggling
survivors where I remember in the second
flexors and that's the more so much that
you put your wings on a shelter to
provide electrical
no comprendo paletas paletas people
progression is over back in villages
mind-boggling selfishness is over 360
can fix on that your problems in
situations in this case I haven't let in
Arizona Monday even has a local
competition for math and among the
weapon exist and the crucifix in it
because I'm winning that whole like
business and personality thing and all
the other guys and girls that are trying
to win they're doing it full-time and so
like a lot of times I'll make fun of
them cuz they're my friends you know I'm
like you know that Gary leaves my side
hostile right yeah like yeah you know
you know so so they're always like holy
[ __ ] that's true thank you
[Music]
[Music]
more stock packet yeah and that's like
so we're going to be able to do more of
it um because I'm going to hire a lot
more against it so it's like just going
to keep giving them more assets right to
provide a life with them that you've
never had yourself over call other
messages or documents over no fun what
is this other person but never set up
another when is you're not I got a new
yesterday yeah
lattes great I got a new yesterday yeah
are you guys doing any marketing
direct-to-consumer on behalf of the
tenants because you want to be come
nestled with study well that's where we
get well whenever you're whenever you
are mature enough to have that
conversation here's my punchline here
depending on how much you do or don't
know about me
will will factor in how much you believe
what I'm about the fit my basic goal
with this company is very simple human
who represents a company it gives me a
penny that whatever the [ __ ] they want
to happen I'll do a better job with that
penny than anybody in the world and
that's why we don't do myself a social
media shock we think we're a attention
shopping so we have every capability
media production creative strategy and
it's all comes down to one thing tell me
what you want to happen and then we try
to go backwards and spending the lowest
amount of money to make it happen
[Music]
another successful trip to London I
think 30 hours this time so pretty good
bunch of client meetings all client
meetings all current clients and a
couple of prospective clients and so I'm
really excited about it a man who's
coming through again doing his thing and
yeah nothing super you know I think give
you a whole lot of crazy footage this
time seeing a lot of means you couldn't
be a part of and just classic like
running a business you know like you
know when I think about the LV 365
episodes or the ambition of maybe maybe
330 because the family vacations or
things of that nature you know some days
are just not going to have anything too
exciting isn't it like most they
shouldn't 85 percent and one of the
challenges
d-roc and another tolerant and we start
we hang out like we're out here like you
know one of the challenges really
figuring out how to at least show the
context of all the meetings I'm actually
having one thing I was telling you right
the other day is like look 80% of the
time I'm spending is on vaynermedia
meetings but the LED is not showing that
because we can't show so much and so you
know right I mean thinking right think
about what happened on this trip I'm
running I'm running a business here I'm
busy I'm running a business and I'm in
meetings that affect other human beings
and so it's hard for me to show them but
you know I think it's a good application
for light to let you guys know like
there's a lot of there's a lot of
hardcore day in and day out business
making but is not being shown and I'm
going to try to do a better job of
figuring out how to interject it even if
we just so show the still of the meeting
starting or the meeting
we we start putting times and start
putting gainer meeting Boehner meeting
Boehner meaning because the scary be
[ __ ] is my side hustle
we see of the fastest-growing hottest
800 person 700 person digital social
agency in the world
[Applause]
okay
welcome committee laughing how to start
start
black market yes
[Music]
information
[Music]
looking professional
I'll keep it here you gotta be loud to
yourself
I was working on the data so a minute
and I feel like nothing that I do
befitting of my insecurities approval is
avaible Jesus is amusing anybody when
other people see Japan is amusing the
views of many concern and something the
way I fail disappointing my realities of
harvesting really only thing I ever
needed was a season of initiative are
many people with original evidence of a
living imprinted I've never given up a
elegiggle taken position if this is
administrators on the tender with
winning there was an effort in a
feminist number they never make it
rather than what happened in feminism
rainy day here in New York I didn't know
that I never chest
there he never secular kademan okay the
rains area
Dave Dave Warren's got that one intro to
that female entrepreneur sports media
site I can do that
how much time do I have in between June
why don't why don't I why don't I leave
San Francisco early and get to LA
Wednesday night and how I getting to
Miami red-eye no shot to do anything out
no shot the catch you earlier one right
yeah but it's not too not too bad in my
opinion I think like not the worst 6:30
to 8:00 and get it done you know what I
mean unless we get a good thing in you
know then I think James then Chicago's
the 24th is fine it's ready to see us
get see it works pretty good okay it's
amazing that I'm at that point in my
career where my assistant is like like a
it's an organ like so attached Tyler's
doing an incredible job not been feeling
well so it's amazing how the piece is
just going back and forth strategizing
it's hand-to-hand combat to partnership
amazing I think one of the things a lot
of people are missing out on as a non
sports got a little bit of success and a
lot of you just starting out but a lot
of you are watching you have some
traction I'm highly recommending
assistance I'm highly recommending teams
around your content Xerox or the andes
of the world I'm highly recommending the
office of the CEO types this chief of
staff it may seem like a luxury and
something that you can't afford but
inevitably there's always a young buck
there's a there's a connection to be
made here in the comment section 44 year
old successful entrepreneur who doesn't
think she or he has the luxury of paying
somebody 7,000 a year to be their chief
of staff and and really help them scale
above and beyond the right-hand CFO type
or controller for our bookkeeper or CEO
o type the right-hand man or what
meanwhile there's 50 to 100 people
watching this right now there are 22 23
24 that don't want to do it the normal
way that don't want to you know week 7
or 8 or 9 years to do interesting work
and so dark and so are willing to play
that chief of staff office of the CEO
office of the founder role part
assistant part content producer part CLO
part psychologist and I don't need that
by the way actually confident and so
thank you and so uh and so I think that
um we need more creativity in the way we
structure our businesses I wish I get a
chief of staff and admin type that
character when I was building one line
we had Brandon but he was really
Director of Operations he was really my
right hand to senior to do to do the 43
things which were 22 little things like
book scheduled this and 18 things I'd
like to follow up with this it's just a
big deal we need to I need to I need to
figure this out I've gotten enormous
amount of value from my content in my
admin and my office of CEO and it's the
best investment I've made in my career
so far and I'm looking to expand it
looking to McGee office Co bigger over
time the clean of teams getting enormous
Liebig tried to admin try to figure out
if we'll do that again double it up
double it up doubling up
you
[Music]